but but I will say Floyd told me a long
time ago why would you give somebody the
privilege of knowing they got your
attention because if you because if you
block them they're like oh they I got to
him right he's like she was like he was
like I don't I don't even you know but
of course he's a billionaire so if you
and Floyd are close you have a Money
Team bracelet now I know plenty of
strippers walking around Los Angeles
right now that have Rolexes per The
Money Team I mean I have Rolexes I have
Rolex I have a Hublot but he that's his
token of appreciation to his team in
general the men and the women the women
get us a a certain type of watching the
men get a certain type of watch and uh
for a long time I wouldn't accept any
gifts from him because I really wanted
him to know the relationship was genuine
was really I just I was just
um I was really inspired to see somebody
come from a Stockton Grand Rapids and
[__] hustle and become a billionaire
off of his talent right and I wanted to
and I had a front row seat to like learn
from this guy I talked to him today
matter of fact on the way over here yeah
I talked to him so I mean yeah I mean
he's been a great supporter so once I on
one of my birthdays several years ago he
gave me the Hublot when he was fighting
I don't don't know if it was Pacquiao
whoever he was fighting he gave me a
Hublot he gave us all of us in the room
of Hublot and then when I got my last
podcast deal with Foxhole he gave me a
Rolex but now I bought on my own watches
you know I bought my own jewelry yeah
you're rich rich man I'm not rich rich
but I'm a 50 million dollar evaluation
Rich Hollywood unlocked
congratulations on that and thank you
for coming man lots of hard work and
dedication hard work and dedication yes
there it is hey Jason Lee my guy thanks
for any time yes sir